our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far stronger than what divides us this
morning well introduce you to a
professor at Texas A&M University he
teaches his students not just through
lectures but also through actions Omar
Villafranca is at the University in
College Station Texas with how kindness
can be a very powerful tool in the
classroom
Omar good morning good morning Henry mu
soma is a business professor here at
Texas A&M and if you look up above me
you can see that same hanging right
there on the on the leadership banner
now every semester he has hundreds of
students but he makes it a point to try
to learn their names so we can make some
sort of personal connection and now
those students are showing the teacher
what they've learned guess what happens
it's hard for students to fall asleep
and dr. Henry mu sohma's class everybody
stand up he's always doing something
extra extra engage an extra supportive
the people cares about most his students
I'm reminded of a friend of mine who
said he's not an educator he's an
agitator but it's not just in his
teaching that dr. mu soma has shown he's
more than willing to do something extra
when Ashton Robinson told dr. mu so much
she couldn't come to class because she
didn't have a babysitter the answer was
simple bring him to class
a little fussiness didn't keep the
professor from finishing his lesson for
Jake Ross dr. musalla meant so much to
him that Jake's fiancee surprised him by
having dr. mu Silva officiate their
wedding he even helped Elizabeth Pope
find a job he knew that I loved business
and medicine and he immediately was like
you know I've got the perfect job for
you but how does someone learn to be
kind for mu soma his education started
more than 8,000 miles away over four
decades ago in the African country of
Zambia both my parents worked hard my
father was one of the first people in
his family to go to college like his
father mu soma wanted an education but
an American one seemed out of reach no
sir too far too expensive
but then he met Albert Cates a US State
Department official he changed his mind
how did he convince you he said here's
my business card
come to my office tomorrow and guess
what Omar that night AMERICA AMERICA God
shed His grace on out sleep I was so
excited he gave me an idea what was it
the possibility Cates helped mu soma
emigrate to America in the mid-90s
doctor finishing Community College he
earned a scholarship at Texas A&M
graduated and started teaching in his
classes he often brings up the story of
Cates and possibility a lesson mu Somis
former student Sam white remembers well
talk about his journey to America and at
the end of every story he would mention
you know how that this man took a man
buy me dinner and convinced him to go to
Texas to study so when it came time to
pay back dr. mu soma for all his
kindness sam knew what to do a Starbucks
card didn't feel right to me right so I
was thinking what could I do for him
that would be awesome he scoured social
media sites and government records for
two years he searched and nearly gave up
finally a breakthrough with the help of
ancestry.com
he received an email from Cates and
helped mu soma reconnect with the past I
ran to the business school that morning
with this email id printed out and I was
trying to play it cool but of course I'm
freaking out right now just like
throwing it what was his reaction it was
complete silence so I wasn't totally
prepared for that because he's one of
the most talkative people I've ever met
and he's always got something to say so
I handed him the email and he read
through it and then he put in his pocket
and said thank you it gave me a hug
decades after their first meeting dr.
musalla and Albert Cates were reunited a
life of kindness that has come full
circle but my son Joshua who's about to
be seven sees me in front of my students
and then when they leave he looks at me
and he wants to put on a little tie when
I
with him and he says daddy I love that
you're kind and if when I'm gone if
that's what my son says of me I'll rest
in peace now one of the life lessons
that Professor mu soma learned from his
father was taking care of his extended
family and he now considers all the
students here at Texas A&M part of his
extended family and that family is
getting bigger every year
Norah well now he has a bigger family of
our audience and I'll love him
Omar what a fantastic story and kindness
cost nothing yeah thank you doctor miss
Ullman it's a beautiful team it is
contagious beautifully done